basically gonna read you kind of a brief
uh overview of kind of what occurred
what's about to happen this morning then
i'll do the same in french and then i'll
take any questions
i apologize it's a little windy a little
cold but
on the morning of february 10th 2022
semi-trailers farm implements and
passenger vehicles began blocking the
canada u.s border at the emirates
support of entry
rcp officers from emerson and morris
detachments and mounted to rcmp
divisional liaison officers
immediately attended the scene and began
to work with the demonstrators to find a
peaceful resolution
through dialogue with the demonstrators
emergency vehicles including police
vehicles as well as some agriculture
transports and other critical events
were allowed through the blocky
apart from these select vehicles all
four lanes of highway 75 and provincial
road 243 remain locked
the number of vehicles taking part in
the blockade
has fluctuated throughout the past 68 at
its peak we estimate approximately 75
vehicles
for vehicles that weren't able to get
through rcp officers diverted traffic to
alternate border crossings in manitoba
as this highway is prone to road
closures due to blizzards in the winter
and flooding in the spring our officers
are well versed in alternate paths of
travel for commercial passenger vehicles
throughout the past six days our
officers continued to use open
communication and a measured and
tempered response
this continuous dialogue between our
officers and the demonstrators enabled
us to reach a resolution yesterday
it is our expectation that at noon today
just an hour just over an hour from now
the remaining demonstrators will begin
to move out of the area and full access
to the emerson port of entry will be
restored
the manitoba rcmp will be coordinating
and escorting the remaining vehicles out
of this area to ensure safe and orderly
departure this is for the safety of
everyone involved
our officers will remain in the area to
ensure that the highway and the border
to the united states remains open and
accessible to all travelers
we'd like to thank our partners canada
border services agency
and the u.s customs and border
protection who provided assistance to
the manitoba rcmp throughout the
duration of the blockade i also want to
thank our provincial partners as well
thank you i'll read the statement of
french
case
is
[Music]
well you have to understand like they
say uh being a national issue we have to
take our time we didn't want to rush in
uh it would have absolutely made no
sense just going in
perhaps making the rest issuing tickets
we probably could have had others just
take their place
communication as you can see
resulted in what we have today just in a
short time this is going to be open
to me it was the best course of action
we're going to have nobody charged
nothing towed nobody injured no arrests
it's a perfect solution so my message is
for six days
well you have to look like you say kind
of every situation is unique it's
different
um
that's the way you have to handle it if
there's something different sometimes
maybe it can be resolved quicker
uh perhaps with a different outcome but
we felt like they say the way the
situation was developing here we needed
to take a prudence and safe measure and
here we are sir
the agreement
what's that part of the agreement there
will be no charges there will be no
arrests
yeah absolutely that was part of the
dialogue and the communication back and
forth they wanted to get their message
across which i believe they have
and we wanted to make sure they
understood kind of where we were coming
at some point like they say our
enforcement might have been needed but
like they say the machines are running
they're warming up in a short time
they'll be on their way
we're aware of his passing or it being
brought up like they say we kind of kept
we had
all the equipment all the personnel
needed we kept going the way we were
doing it and it's worked for us today
and like i said it's
[Music]
that's resolved situations that could
develop right now we'll focus on today
we'll learn from what we had and
obviously have a good dialogue with
everyone that's been here and like they
say we're hoping that might say it as of
today this will be over
well we're not aware of anything at this
moment but let me see kind of
continue with what we're doing if
something develops
foreign
um
yes
um
well you have to take that into
consideration there's been no uh
information just so that that was a
possibility but it's part of our
planning it's part of contingencies if
we're to develop
we have to address it we have to be
prepared for them
sorry paul i came running late here
tell me a bit about um the negotiations
over the past week that that led
lightning
decided to leave here well we basically
had uh
you know every day we've had negotiators
here from our team
uh basically having that dialogue open
at times there would have been
discussions at times it would have been
quiet but the idea was to keep the
communication back and forth
related to what we wanted to how it was
going to advance and
obviously on their side what they want
so like they say we kept that dialogue
over
and
the outcome is what we want no one got
hurt
we have a highway that's going to open
and trade can uh resume at this point
[Music]
foreign
right now no right now we have no one
arrested uh nothing seized uh they're
removing all their equipment as they
stated so they've kept their end of the
park and right now like i said we're
doing our part and
hopefully within a few hours this will
be uh open highway and the plan is uh
yeah they're going to be headed
northbound towards highway 14 and then
head westbound
no they'll be headed north from 75 up to
i believe 14 where they'll head west
any other questions
okay thank you very much
good job hold the bike thank you
uh